the sunflower star is a terrifying  predator  [Music]  it's more than three feet wide is  replete with 15,000 two feet and is one  of the fastest animals in its bio  [Music]  this cockle is trying desperately to  escape its many harm to  the sunflower sea star is capable of  moving up to 200 feet an hour more than  enough to overcome the coffee  it even possesses the ability to sense  the waterborne chemical residue of dead  animals making it an efficient scavenger  and when other predators such as this  crab target the sea star it can detach  an arm and make a getaway  [Music]  it will later regrow the arm and a whole  new sea star can even grow from the lost  arm if it retained a large portion of  the central body  [Music]